en 2019 ils étaient plus de six mille
cinq cents enfants de djihadistes
étrangers réunis ici dans ce scandale
hall au nord de la syrie où les
conditions de vie sont déplorables des
familles entières et des français
également une situation humanitaire qui
alerte la communauté internationale la
france est pointée du doigt par la
commission nationale consultative des
droits de l'homme dans sa gestion des
rapatriements de ces djihadistes
c'est le cas pour ces onze français
capturés en syrie et condamné à mort en
irak en 2019 au nom des valeurs de notre
république et du respect des droits
fondamentaux
la commission nationale consultative des
droits de l'homme demandent au
gouvernement d'organiser sans tarder le
retour de ses ressortissants pour être
jugé
si la france ne les rapatrie pas elle
bafoue ses valeurs et engagements
internationaux puisque l'hexagone est
contre la peine de mort
pour le gouvernement la situation de ses
djihadistes it une poudrière
plusieurs sondages récents ayant montré
l'hostilité de l'opinion au rapatriement
de djihadistes pourtant le mois dernier
nicole belloubet avait pour la première
fois émis l'hypothèse de la possibilité
de juger en france les ressortissants
détenus par les kurdes de syrie
jusqu'aux récentes évolutions nous
pensions à la possibilité de mettre en
place avec d'autres états européens un
tribunal mixte en irak pour juger les
djihadistes étrangers que leur pays ne
veulent pas reprendre un tribunal que
nous aurions appuyé mais la donne a
changé
dans ce cas là il n'est plus possible de
les juger sur place
je ne vois pas d'autre solution que de
rapatrier ces gens en france tous
combattants terroristes qui seraient
rapatriés serait judiciariser comme nous
l'avons toujours fait
les forces kurdes de syrie de leur côté
ont réitéré ce dimanche leur besoin
d'une aide internationale juridique pour
juger sur place les milliers de
djihadistes de dèche
mais depuis la déclaration de la
ministre de la justice
aucune avancée majeure n'a eu lieu et
plusieurs collectifs sont montés au
créneau pour dénoncer l'inaction du
gouvernement face à cette situation
humanitaire désastreuse
ce n'est pas seulement le jugement de
ces djihadistes qui est remis en cause
mais également la situation des enfants
pour m bailly avocat d'une dizaine de
familles qui cherchent à faire revenir
en france leurs enfants il est certain
que le gouvernement ne fait preuve
d'aucune bonne volonté
si on arrive finalement à une politique
au cas par cas c'est aussi parce que
l'opinion publique est aujourd'hui
encore hostile au rapatriement de ces
tout petits on le comprend on comprend
cette peur légitime mais il nous semble
nous avocats saisis par les grands
parents il nous semble que ce n'est pas
ce n'est pas la hauteur d'un pays comme
la france
ce n'est pas la hauteur de notre
patrimoine juridique de laisser des
enfants dans des camps dans lesquels ils
meurent de malnutrition dans les camps
où ils meurent de maladies et les
chiffres parlent d'eux mêmes les
conditions de vie particulièrement
difficiles ont entraîné la mort de plus
de 517 personnes donc 371 enfants en
2019 dans le camp d'alcool depuis
septembre dernier la commission
nationale consultative des droits de
l'homme exhortent l'état français à gien
[Musique]